Joe Biden has another huge headache in
his growing classified document Scandal
his own attorney general forced to
appoint a special counsel because it
looks like Joe was leaving secret files
all over the place the second Trove of
documents were found in his garage in
Wilmington Delaware right next to his
prize muscle car the president is
downplaying the Discovery and using the
classic Corvette defense
classified material next to your
Corvette what were you thinking
let me uh I'm going to get a chance to
speak on all this God willing soon but
as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvettes in a
lock garage okay so it's not like you're
sitting out in the street but anyway
yes as well as my Corvette
um but as I said earlier this week
people know I take classified documents
and classified materials seriously they
discovered a small number of documents
of classified markings and storage areas
and file cabinets in my home in my in my
my my personal Library yeah no one ever
breaks into a lock garage no one ever
opens the garage door and leaves it open
possible today the doj discovered
another document stashed in Biden's
house the president's lawyers claim they
were inadvertently misplaced
there are a lot of big questions here
and the White House is more than happy
to answer them all
I would refer to Department of Justice
or my colleagues in the council's office
but again I'm just not going to go
beyond what the president said I'm not
going to go beyond what the president
said I'm not going to go beyond what the
president said again I'm just not going
to go into this particulars or the
specifics of what the Department of
Justice did again there's an ongoing
process it's being reviewed I don't have
any uh don't have more to share again it
wasn't because there is a process an
ongoing process that is occurring the
process and it looks like the view and a
Democrat Congressman have a solid theory
on the documents
a luckier person than Donald Trump just
as we're this close to getting them but
you know how
you feel like apple research to you does
it feel like the Republicans are behind
it
did originally but I'm sorry but not not
now I'm also aware of the fact that
things can be planted on people things
can be planted in places and then
discovered conveniently that may be what
has occurred here
Joy obviously stealing that jacket from
Michael Keaton in Beetlejuice
that's where I saw it before how do
it's not has it been planted Geraldo
maybe this is the work of the Russians
no it's the work of the Russians the
same people who who colluded with Trump
it's Preposterous it's ridiculous uh as
is this entire scandal in my view I
think that this is a Much Ado About
Nothing uh this is uh uh the Republicans
having a chance to go nah nah nah you uh
uh you raided Mar-A-Lago now look at uh
Joe's Garage and uh so forth that's what
Joe deserve it Joe deserves it Joe got
up on his high horse I that's why he
deserves it I think that because of his
uh his Stern and uh self-righteous and
inflated outrage faux outrage over the
president uh president Trump's uh a
Mar-A-Lago stash uh then he looks like
the hypocrite that he apparently is and
I think that that's what's most damaging
it's his own hypocrisy it's so amazing
Dana because these events happen so
close you know with trump it was in
August and here it is now and you don't
so you don't have to say imagine if this
was Trump you don't have to imagine it
because it already happened they would
Cruise they did crucify him yeah I hope
that the media is going to update all of
there this isn't as bad as Trump visual
aids that they've been working on
because this story keeps growing I'm
feeling it will grow a little bit more
as well I don't know how the documents
how that got revealed I hope that we do
find that out I also want to know what
did they know and when did they know it
at the White House especially in the
Press office because if they weren't
told about the November 2nd Discovery
that's something right if that epic or
did they decide to also play on play it
down and not comment until after the
midterms until it got there and I do
think that you know how Biden said
um how irresponsible could you be that's
going that's like the new what
difference does it make yeah which was
what Hillary Clinton that was the theme
of the Hillary Clinton campaign how
irresponsible could you be and you could
take that line to the Biden
Administration oh on almost every single
issue another point is that a locked
garage is a defense is his password
password yeah because that that's not
going to cut it and imagine if president
Trump has said that yeah yeah like oh no
yeah it's just like don't worry my
wife's closet is a lock on it this is
this is absurd the other thing is that
it's a really it's really bad for the
government and for people who actually
deal with classified information last
February the government actually secured
a prison term for a former Defense
Department employee who mishandled
classified materials and if you read
this article it was actually a CNN piece
you find out that what she had done is
she was working on a thesis she needed
to work on the thesis covet happened you
couldn't get into the building she took
a classified document home she had
people over to her room or they had a
dinner party and another colleague sees
these documents and turns her in because
that's what you are supposed to do yeah
so she's in prison and these guys are
like that's amazing that's incredible I
don't know what a thing that's
horrifying yeah you know uh Kennedy
there were some conspiracies uh put
forth on The View suggesting it might be
Republicans but couldn't you argue yeah
couldn't you argue that it's more if
there's any conspiracy it would be it
would come from the people who don't
want Biden to run which is like 80 of
the Democrats and mayor Pete so and
maybe if they were trying to tank his
campaign they would have planted those
documents people within the Biden Circle
uh at his pen office in DC and it is
Wilmington Delaware home but that didn't
happen because you know Geraldo thinks
this isn't a big deal I think they all
do it I think every president squirrels
away documents I don't know if he was
trying to hide something or he's just
incredibly irresponsible a two things
strike me here one he doesn't know
what's in them he doesn't know how they
got there he doesn't know how long
they've been there he has no idea who
put them there that's a real issue if
you're talking about top secret
classified information and yeah we
should be concerned about that
considering uh the the people
potentially spies who are surrounding
politicians like Dianne Feinstein and
Eric swalwell that's number one number
two after the week in politics we had
last week with the speaker drama you
cannot deny that the Matrix is real and
and someone is writing every chapter of
this because I honestly thought this
week it was going to get maybe boring
yeah and then here we have like oh there
there was a third trench of documents
like thank you overlords yes you know
Jesse I do think this is important a
because it's clear that Joe doesn't know
what the hell is going on right and B
this is to me is worse than Watergate
well that's Joe's defense yeah I don't
know what's in my house I don't know
what's in my office but the China who
put it there and I don't know what the
documents say he's the idiot defense it
is it is and then you start looking at
the stuff about the University of
Pennsylvania and it's it's kind of
interesting yeah so he opens up the
Biden Center at the UPenn and then China
pours money to you Ben and then he gets
paid with that money and then as a
reward he sends the UPenn president to
be the ambassador to Germany it's great
and then they Lobby against all the
tenacious uh aggressive investigations
of Chinese Espionage once they opened
the Biden Center Greg did you know that
next to a Corvette is the safest place
on Earth you took the Corvette and you
drove it to Taiwan right China wouldn't
invade yes now have you ever had a
garage door and you hit the button and
it closes but all of a sudden it goes
back up because a leaf is dangling into
the beam and it won't let you close it
that's what we're doing that's where it
knocks that's Fort Knox Biden's
automatic garage door opener is the
safest thing you can have how many times
you've been driving you can imagine him
in the Corvette Jill Jill gotta turn
around I think I left the garage door
open did they have a garage sale
I mean how do we know Hunter oh guess
what Mom and Dad are in Rehoboth bring
the strippers over Hunter these things
are there for seven years you're saying
Hunter didn't party while his parents
were out you're saying Hunter didn't
have Jackie bow the Chinese spy was
working for the Biden campaign over at
the house did he have Patrick ho the guy
that was indicted for Espionage over at
the house what business partner of
Hunter went over to the house that's
what I want to know
there's no evidence that anything was
compromised zero evidence we don't know
that
the investigation Geraldo
I would be interested to know because
Joe Biden ran his basement campaign from
the house where these classified
documents were how many campaign staff
members were going in and out of there
for a year how many uh guys setting up
the Wi-Fi you know the Geek Squad how do
we know the Geek Squad wasn't really the
Russians and they're going and plugging
things in the garage oops look at these
Ukraine documents click click send them
boom it's so easy to get into this
situation Geraldo you have no idea also
Biden is using the Hillary defense which
I love he's saying you know what my
lawyers have looked into all of my
offices and determined that these are
the classified documents that we're
going to turn over the rest of the
documents we found mostly about hunter's
wedding and yoga it gets away with it
would you care would you care at all
I don't even care about more loggers I
care about coralago also this is so
stupid and it really makes me angry
Trump's under investigation by two
special counsels Biden's under
investigation his son is under
investigation so these lawyers who you
know I hate are basically going to
determine who the next president's going
to be you can indict one not the other
you can indict neither you can indict
both you could blackmail the prisoners
why are like a handful of lawyers and
prosecutors gonna determine who the next
president is going to be I mean they did
it with Hillary they investigated Trump
before he became president during his
presidency after his president now they
have Joe and his son under lock I mean
the FBI this these guys it's too much
investigation car alago Carlo just come
up with that took me all day really good
for you good for you but this isn't it
it was it's just it's a disturbing Trend
the bidens just leave stuff everywhere
they leave guns and trash cans Diaries
and halfway houses babies and strippers
what do you think yeah baby's inside
strips what do you think the chances are
that they they find more documents and
more homes and more options what are the
chances the chances I say are good huh
but don't hold me to it I might change
my mind hi when I'm Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now